something you may or may not know
prostitution is legal in the state of
Nevada
of course double room marino right now
we're pulling up to a place called the
chicken hole establishes run by our
friend Claire you think the things that
they do in here would relax somebody but
it has the opposite effect
how you doing hi Claire what's going on
today sweetie
well you know what you got a squirt
press I don't know I didn't call it
upstairs called down shut all right hey
Joe get over here come over here hey
come on let's go let me show you
something all right look let me just
tell you let me just tell you okay I
just finished my lovemaking
I just did my lovemaking over there all
right look I want to clean myself up I
want to take a shower so here be respect
guys I walk in here look at this look
these walls empty and there's not a sign
in here this as employees must wash
hands that stayed in the bottom you got
a whorehouse
you still got a port but you're loud
okay you know what
how many times you've been here Andrew
25 26 and today you even completed my
days the day they let me tell you
something it's been brewing it's been
bruised I'm thinking about myself I'm
thinking the day I'm finishing my love
Megan I got James all over me okay mail
juices I got the female juices on me
when you blink you got juices just
everywhere but let me tell you something
so I gotta clean those juices off but
when I'm walking here I see that no one
else is cleaning their juice I'm like my
god I'm making loving juice but let me
tell you something you know if you want
to wash go to a KOA campground pay a
quarter for a goddamn shower oh she says
thank you like I get that rip okay okay
shut up let's go
[Music]